Olá você já parou para pensar no Impacto
que a disfunção mitocondrial pode ter na
sua vida as mitocôndrias conhecidas como
as usinas de energia das células são
extremamente fundamentais para manter
nosso corpo funcionando com energia e
vitalidade Quando essas pequenas usinas
começam a falhar os primeiros sinais são
cansaço fadiga falta de disposição
fraquesa muscular insônia e sonolência
de urna mas a história não para por aí a
disfunção mitocondrial pode estar por
trás de problemas muito mais sérios
contribuindo para o desenvolvimento de
doenças crônicos
degenerativas especialmente as
neurodegenerativas como Alzheimer paxon
e também doenças autoimunes
cardiovasculares e metabólicas como
diabetes e resistência insulina e não
podemos esquecer do envelhecimento
precoce e até do Câncer as mitocôndrias
são fundamentais pra saúde e quando elas
não estão funcionando bem os impactos
podem ser devastadores vamos entender
melhor Como isso acontece e também
conhecer um suplemento que pode proteger
essas usinas de energia que são tão
vitais paraa nossa vida pessoal esse
suplemento é o pqq ou pirolo quinolina
quinona que mesmo em doses pequenas pode
ser muito útil para melhorar muitos
sintomas e prevenir algumas doenças ela
tem sido extensivamente estudada nos
últimos anos para vocês entenderem de
forma básica as mitocôndrias transformam
os nutrientes que ingerimos energia que
o nosso corpo usa para realizar todas as
suas funções desde respirar até correr
por exemplo Então olha só a importância
das mitocôndrias paraa nossa saúde e
esse suplemento
pqq protege as nossas mitocôndrias e até
pode ajudar a regenerar novas
mitocôndrias a pqq é encontrada
naturalmente no solo em alimentos como
Nat que é a soja fermentada também na
salsa pimentão espinafre mamão Ki chá
verde entre outros mas encontramos
apenas pequenas quantidades dela nesses
alimentos ela também é produzida
naturalmente no nosso corpo a partir de
aminoácidos e é encontrada nos tecidos e
fluidos corporais assim como os tecidos
e fluidos do nosso corpo as nossas
mitocôndrias também precisam de pqq para
catalisar reações que produzem energia e
para proteger as próprias mitocôndrias
de danos o envelhecimento começa a nível
celular dentro das células e o pqq é uma
maneira inteligente interessante de
proteger essas células além de ajudar a
melhorar as partes do corpo que possuem
maior densidade de energia como o
cérebro e o coração os sintomas de
disfunção mitocondrial podem variar mas
geralmente incluem em sinais como
crescimento lento fraqueza muscular
cansaço constante problemas neurológicos
dificuldades gastrointestinais e um
risco maior de infecções Mas falando em
cérebro esse suplemento pqq tem um
benefício enorme paraa função pra saúde
neurológica Pesquisas mostram que o pqq
protege e melhora a sobrevivência dos
neurônios ao estimular a síntese do
fator de crescimento neuronal o ngf ngf
que é importante pro crescimento
manutenção e sobrevivência de
determinados neurônios inclusive em
certas células de suporte do cérebro a
glia que são encontradas no sistema
nervoso central e também olha o
interessante o uso de pqq pode melhorar
a função das células neurais danificadas
pela proteína disforme betamil Loide que
é uma característica da doença de
alzheimer Além disso ele pode prevenir a
formação de proteínas Alfa sinucleína
que é
marcador da doença de paxo e a pqq não
só protege o cérebro mas também pode
melhorar o aprendizado e a memória Isso
significa que ao consumir mais pqq seja
através da alimentação ou por
suplementação você não estará apenas
Protegendo o seu cérebro de danos
futuros mas também poderá notar uma
melhoria na sua capacidade de pensar
capacidade de lembrar das coisas do dia
a dia um outro benefício interessante na
fqq é a sua capacidade de reduzir a
inflamação no corpo e olha só onde ela
atua Olha que interessante pessoal ela
diminui os níveis de biomarcadores
inflamatórios como é o caso da proteína
C reativa e a eter leucina 6 são
marcadores de inflamação Então esse
suplemento também contribui para uma
resposta inflamatória mais equilibrada
no corpo não deixa ela ficar exagerada
então alguns estudos mostraram que mesmo
Moses baixas ela foi capaz de melhorar
esses biomarcadores inflamatórios outros
benefícios da pqq possui forte atividade
antioxidante é capaz de neutralizar
radicais livres de maneira eficaz muito
mais eficaz até do que é da vitamina C
que é outro antioxidante muito bem
conhecido a pqq também ajuda na função
imune de defesa uma deficiência de pqq
foi associado a disfunções imunológicas
como é o caso da diminuição da
capacidade de resposta do próprio
sistema de defesa imune Então ela pode
fortalecer as defesas do nosso organismo
contra microorganismos seja vírus
bactérias ou outros além disso a pqq
pode ajudar na modulação de doenças
autoimunes tanto pela sua capacidade
modular a resposta imunológica quanto
pela redução dos marcadores
inflamatórios isso pode ser benéfico
para equilibrar condições como é o caso
de doenças autoimunes lupus Artrite
reumatoide codite Hashimoto e outras
doenças semelhantes agora se você acorda
sempre cansado mesmo depois de uma no de
sono pqq pode ser uma aliada inteligente
ela tem mostrado em estudos que melhora
a qualidade do Sono ajuda você a
adormecer mais facilmente e ter um sono
mais contínuo mais reparador além disso
a pqq pode ajudar a aumentar a sua
energia durante o dia e combater aquela
sensação constante de fadiga e quando
usada junto com a cozema q10 os
benefícios podem ser ainda mais
evidentes ajudando você a enfrentar o
dia a dia com mais exposição pessoal
como vocês perceberam a lista de
benefícios para saúde que vem do pqq é
bem longa já que ela atua como
antioxidante e também atua na disfunção
mitocondrial Então ela pode ter uma ação
inteligente de apoio de suporte em
diversas condições de saúde eu poderia
ficar aqui mais tempo horas até falando
sobre como ela pode ajudar em várias
situações e eu convido vocês a lerem os
artigos que eu vou deixar na descrição
do vídeo ok mas vamos focar na
suplementação e como vamos utilizar como
eu já mencionei a pqq é encontrada em
alimentos mas sempre pequenas
quantidades que muitas vezes não são
suficientes para esse benefício todos
que nós estamos falando aqui Então
dependendo de como está a sua saúde
geral a sua alimentação e a sua
capacidade de absorção Pode ser que você
não consiga obter o suficiente da dieta
Então nesse caso é top um suplemento pqq
que pode ajudar tanto na prevenção quant
tratamento dessas condições que nós
falamos especialmente se você tem
sintomas de baixa energia como fadiga
cansaço e também problemas de memória
então se você começar a tomar suplemento
de pqq em algumas semanas você pode
perceber se está funcionando ou não pois
você deverá sentir uma melhora com mais
energia um pensamento mais claro e um
bem-estar geral Então você já deve ter
ouvido falar da combinação entre pqq e a
famosa com enzima q10 A coq10 então
trata-se uma dupla poderosa que vai
potencializar os seus efeitos graças à
sinergia entre eles a cque 10 quando
combinado com pqq se torna ainda mais
eficaz e prontamente disponível pro seu
corpo Então essa parceria é uma
estratégia inteligente para quem deseja
sim otimizar energia a s cardiovascular
a função cerebral especialmente à medida
que nós envelhecemos e olha só que
interessante a coqu 10 é um antioxidante
que também facilita a reciclagem de
outros antioxidantes então quando você
usa coqu 10 com pqq você turbina a
capacidade de antioxidante no seu corpo
pois a Coq 10 a cozema que1 vai ajudar
na reciclagem da pqq e de outros
antioxidantes um detalhe importante é
que tanto a coenzima q10 quanto a pqq
São solúveis em gordura são
lipossolúveis então o melhor jeito de
tomar os dois é com uma refeição que
tenha gordura agora sobre o melhor
suplemento pqq você deve tomar cuidado
com a marca procure uma marca confiável
e sempre siga as orientações do seu
médico de preferência escolha uma pqq
que seja extraída de bactérias
fermentadas em vez das versões
sintéticas e comece com uma dose baixa
vai aumentando aos poucos de forma lenta
para avaliar sua tolerância e o quanto
isso tá beneficiando você então vale
destacar que ainda não existe uma
dosagem padrão não definida para pqq a
dosagem ideal pode variar e pode ser
ajustada pelo seu médico ou médica de
acordo com as suas necessidades
individuais mas pesquisas sugerem que a
pqq pode oferecer benefícios mesmo em
doses tão baixas quanto 2 MG a maioria
dos Suplementos disponíveis no mercado
você encontra em dosagens que variam
entre 10 a 20 MG uma faixa geralmente
considerada bem segura e eficaz para a
maioria das pessoas em relação aos
efeitos adversos foi observado que altas
doses de pqq pode causar alguns efeitos
colaterais inclusive pode causar efeitos
tóxicos nos rins então cuidado mas isso
aconteceu em doses muito altas mesmos Ok
então não é porque estou falando que a
pqq é um suplemento muito bom
fundamental para as mitocôndrias e útil
no auxílio de diversas doenças crônicas
que você vai sair tomando uma dose aí
super Alta ou exagerada mesmo que vai
ficar muito caro correto lembre-se
daquele velho ditado que nunca sai de
moda di diferença entre remédio e Veneno
tá sempre na dose portanto nunca
ultrapasse doses de acima de 40 MG por
dia de pqq por tua conta própria Ok
muito obrigado pela sua atenção um
grande abraço um beijo no seu coração e
você feira até o próximo vídeo